vous souvenez-vous du cic cice comme
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi ont relancé le marché du
travail chaque année ce sont 20
milliards d'euros injectés par l'état
dans les entreprises
l'effort que nous engageons marquera
notre destin collectif
mais depuis janvier 2019 s'est terminée
au revoir mais alors le cic eux at il
vraiment été la révolution annoncée on
fait le bilan calmement
l'objectif annoncé en 2012 créé trois
cent mille emplois en allégeant les
cotisations sociales des entreprises
mais à peine annoncé le cicr est
critiquée qu'un oblige les entreprises à
investir cet argent dans la recherche et
développement dans la compétitivité mais
elles peuvent utiliser autre chose par
exemple au désendettement ou à la
distribution des dividendes
cela dit il y a bien eu des créations de
postes surtout dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises
nous allons recruter un directeur
qualité à responsable commercial donc
va nous permettre d'accentuer le
développement bien que la mesure
présente un bémol à l'embauché à durée
indéterminée quand on recrute cannes car
dans une entreprise c'est pas juste pour
la durée d'une mesure gouvernementale
alors qu'on fait des entreprises de ce
crédit d'impôt voilà une bonne caisse
fin 2016
trente deux pour cent des entreprises
disent n avoir utilisé pour créer de
nouveaux emplois
elles étaient plus nombreuses à en avoir
profité pour réaliser des
investissements ou pour augmenter leurs
marges 29% ont utilisé le cic yeux pour
augmenter les salaires et 5 % des
entreprises pour baisser leurs prix au
coeur de la polémique pendant ces six
années de crédit d'impôt les grandes
entreprises qui n'avait pas forcément
besoin de ce cadeau fiscal en 2015 par
exemple 29,4 % de l'argent dédié au cic
au leur a été alloué
c'est plus que les micro entreprises et
les entreprises de taille intermédiaire
mais moins que les petites et moyennes
entreprises
en revanche ce qui a posé question c'est
l'utilisation que ces grandes
entreprises en ont fait en 2014
l'oeil du 20 heures de france 2 mené
l'enquêté air france a bien touché 41,9
millions d'euros de cic eux mais ses
effectifs français sont en baisse
constante depuis trois ans certaines
auraient utilisé le cic eu pour
rétribuer leurs actionnaires ce qui
était interdit
je crois que c'est pas bien au total
entre 2013 et 2018 87 milliards d'euros
de crédits d'impôts ont été versés alors
quel bilan
selon le comité de suivi du cic eu cent
mille emplois ont été créés ou
sauvegardés
loin des 300 milles annoncée en 2012
[Musique]